ukrainians continue to be confronted
with scenes of bodies littering streets
as they return to towns and villages
abandoned by russian forces
ukraine's leaders want russia to be held
accountable for what they call crimes
against humanity
the mayor of the ukrainian town of
motijn 50 kilometers west of kiev local
residents say was killed in an
execution-style slaying
her husband and son by her side
this is our mayor olga patrina her
husband igor vasilevich and son sasha
these are our local residents who were
kidnapped from the village on march 23rd
reports are also emerging of russian
soldiers using tactics associated with
criminal gangs
to hunt down ukrainian volunteers
in the village of severinka the body of
a 44 year old member of the ukrainian
territorial defense found in a sewage
maintenance shaft
his wife said he'd been kidnapped by
russian soldiers
in our village there were traitors who
showed them where they were but most of
them escaped as did my son
but he took another man as well
in bucha one woman found her husband's
body in a basement nearly two weeks
after reporting him missing
when i came down i recognized him by his
shoes his trousers his face was
mutilated his body was cold
they turned him over a little my
neighbor still has a picture of his face
he had been shot in the head mutilated
tortured
ukrainian officials are calling for
forensic investigations by the united
nations and the international court of
justice a global reckoning for what has
happened in this country what president
vladimir zielinski has described as a
genocide
hundreds of people killed tortured
executed civilians bodies on the streets
booby-trapped areas even the bodies of
the dead are booby-trapped widespread
aftermath of looting concentrated evils
visited our land the killers
executioners rapists marauders who call
themselves an army and who deserve only
death after what they've done
even in the safety of shelters in la viv
ukrainians carry their anger with them
if i could go to war i would go i swear
i would go i would strangle and kill
these filth with my hands hatred pure
hatred the nazis did not do things as
this scum does peaceful people are being
shot at from morning till night houses
are collapsing families fall apart
children die every day you hear a child
died a child died how many you can't
count it anymore how many civilians died
we saw it all with our own eyes whether
or not russians accused of war crimes
ever face consequences ukrainians who
have left homes and loved ones behind
say young and old will struggle
to cope with the trauma of what they've
seen for the rest of their lives
zayn basravi al-jazeera lev
ukraine's second largest city has been
hit by more russian shelling
seven people have been killed and
another 12 injured assad beg is in
kharkiv
this is a point of impact where the
russian missile hit
now
it is clearly a residential area now
what they fire out are these small
tiny pellets
these metal pellets and you can see the
marks all around they have broken the
windows
you can see
all along this wall
what the the damage that these do
you've got marks all done around this
wall you've got glass on the floor where
it's smashed now they have a radius of
around 100 to 150
meters and there's a playground there
the car wind car window here was smashed
even a van all the way back there has
been hit
and it has a radius of 100 to 155 meters
and we believe that one person was
killed at this location again in the
middle of a residential area there's two
playgrounds either side of me
it could have been
way worse
in this location two people were killed
there's still
blood on the floor that you can see
through that sand that the emergency
services have put over there's still
bread on the bench from those people
that were
sitting there
and
the the missile landed
right in the middle of this playground
well joining us to talk about the latest
human rights watch report on ukraine is
ida sawyer she's the crisis and conflict
director for human rights watch joining
us from washington d.c thanks very much
for speaking to us on al jazeera so i'm
just looking at your latest report
titled apparent war crimes in
russian-controlled areas where you talk
about summary executions and other grave
abuses
tell us what you've documented
thanks for having me so we at human
rights watch we've documented several
cases of russian military forces
committing apparent war crimes against
civilians in areas that were occupied by
the russian forces in cherniyev kharkiv
and the kiev regions of ukraine so this
includes one case in the village of
staria by kiev in cherney of region
north of kiev where russian soldiers
rounded up at least six men on february
27th and later executed them we spoke to
the mother of one of the men who was
nearby when her son and another man were
apprehended and she later saw the bodies
of her son and the other five men she
said there were gunshot wounds on their
heads and their hands were tied behind
their their backs
in another case on march 4th russian
forces in bucha just 30 kilometers
northwest of keith rounded up five men
and summarily executed one of them
a witness told us how soldiers forced
the five men to kneel on the side of the
road and then they shot one of the men
in the back of the head right we also
documented how in march 6 russian
soldiers in forzal threw a smoke grenade
into a basement and then shot a woman
and a 14 year old child as they emerged
tell us how you collated this
information and what sort of message
methods pardon me you used to gather
this information and to document this
so for this research we we interviewed
uh people who were witnesses and and
victims of these these violations uh
some by phone and some who were able to
interview in person after they had uh
escaped these these areas where the
violations took place
obviously accountability is so important
in in um during wars i mean what what
are you hoping that this
report will will actually achieve
so the the cases that we documented
including the summary executions as well
as a case of repeated rape are
violations of the laws of war which
clearly prohibit willful killing rape
and other sexual violence and anyone who
orders or deliberately commits such acts
or aids and abets them is responsible
for war crimes commanders of forces who
knew or had reason to know about such
crimes but did not attempt to stop them
or punish those responsible are also
commonly liable for war crimes as a
matter of command responsibility and as
you're saying all parties to the arms
conflict any armed conflict in fact are
obligated to abide by uh international
humanitarian law just tell us what those
responsibilities are under international
law and human rights law
so under the international humanitarian
law the laws of war
all parties to a conflict are prohibited
from willfully targeting civilians or
civilian targets um they're prohibited
from carrying out indiscriminate or
reckless uh or disproportionate attacks
that could target civilians or civilian
targets as well as these cases of woeful
killing rape sexual violence torture
inhumane treatment of captured
combatants and civilians in custody um
so these are all violations of the laws
of war and we hope that the ukrainian
authorities they've launched their own
investigations there's also the
international criminal court which has
launched an investigation into crimes
committed during this conflict and
we hope that they will carry out
credible impartial investigations
looking at potential violations by all
sides thank you so much ida sawyer for
speaking to us from washington d.c
thanks for having me